by Jason of Beverly Hills it's time for
the players to get their Rings here are
your 2022 NBA NBA champion
State Warriors
won Toscano Anderson
Witherspoon
[Applause]
[Music]
Andre
Iguodala
[Applause]
[Music]
Jonathan
combinga
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Moses Moody
[Applause]
[Music]
Jordan pool
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Thompson
[Applause]
[Music]
Stephen Curry
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
if you look up there that is a very
lonely flag we want another one
[Applause]
from the ground up the Golden State
Warriors select select election hard
works
[Applause]
attention to detail
craftsmanship
the Relentless pursuit of greatness
from the foundation
the rafters
we built this the Ducks Dynasty is still
very much alive from the ground up
look at what we made
[Applause]
[Music]
it's time to raise the Warriors seventh
Championship Banner
here is the all-time three-point record
holder the All-Star MVP the Western
Conference playoffs MVP the NBA Finals
MVP Stephen Curry
this is a very special night
celebrating our fourth championship in
eight years
from game six of the 2019 finals in
Oakland to game six of the 22 to 2022
finals here at Chase Center
um this was a long long journey and uh
it's such an amazing honor to be able to
celebrate our fourth Banner seventh and
franchise history here with y'all
tonight so thank y'all very much
we want to
continue to use our platform and the
opportunity to shout out a very special
member of the basketball Community
Brittany griner's birthday is today
she's 32 years old
we want to continue to let her name be
known and we pray that it's been 243
days since she's been wrongfully
incarcerated in Russia we hope that she
comes home soon and everybody's doing
their part to get home
and everything that we do here is about
our team and there are a lot of members
of our team on the court but there are a
lot of members of our team off the court
and our director of player
Administration and player programs the
name mcguigan I want to bring you out in
there you are a special special part of
our organization you deserve all the
recognition for making things go she's
been here for 18 years
you might not know her but we do y'all
give it up for the name mcguigan she's
gonna get her ring tonight in front of
everybody come on out in there
come get your ring come get your ring
y'all give it up
stay out here you gotta stay out here
now come on out here
and last but not least y'all ready
we got three beautiful banners up there
we gotta add one more to the collection
so we're gonna count down from five it's
coming down here from Center Court so
y'all make sure y'all put your eyes
right here five four three two one let's
go got a really big team and they need
some really big Rings they need some
really nice things better be coming with
no strings better be coming with no
strings we need some really nice things
we need some really big rings I got a
really big team I got a really big team
they need some really big Rings they
need some really nice things better be
coming with no strings better be coming
with no strings we need some really nice
things we need some really big rings I
got a really big team man what a Time
to be alive
you and yours first me and mine are we
talking six are we talking teens oh you
switching sides wanna come with me
look at the aisle on me I do not chase
girls
[Music]
like
me man we want it all don't get too
involved
[Music]
that's cool all right four championships
in the last eight years six trips to the
finals they going back fellas I think
they are you know uh